le patrimoine on en parle depuis
maintenant presque trois quarts d'heure
et on va s'intéresser à l'histoire plus
particulièrement d'une commune celle de
guyancourt il ya plusieurs rendez-vous
proposé à guyancourt à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines durant les
journées du patrimoine
et nous recevons donc sur ce plateau
liliane gex bonsoir vous êtes auteur
guillon courtoise vous avez écrit
plusieurs ouvrages sur l'histoire de
guyancourt et isabelle gourmelen
responsable du service des archives
communales et du patrimoine à la mairie
de guyancourt bonsoir donc à toutes les
deux plusieurs rendez vous lui en cours
à une histoire particulièrement riche
c'est un petit peu la première question
que j'ai envie de vous lancer oui tout à
fait une histoire riche et variée
puisque patrimoine rural on en trouve on
en a parlé sur ce plateau tout à leur
patrimoine aussi plus moderne avec les
sculptures puisque on est quand même
dans une ville d'art et d'histoire donc
sculpture moderne architecture
contemporaine mais nous cette année on
va vraiment s'intéresser plus
particulièrement au patrimoine rural au
coeur de la ville au village et ferme
aussi aux fermes tout classer tout cas
c'est encore sur l'encours à l'église
aussi puisqu'on a un actualité chargée
dans le village on a eu des sondages
archéologiques
on a redécouvert une fresque aussi dans
l'église qui étaient cachées patrimoine
caché sous des enduits histoire de grand
bourg montre à quelle période à peu près
à vous pouvez la faire remonter à la
préhistoire sang avait repéré des traces
les choses dans les archers que vous
avez pu conserver alors dans les
archives pas de trace écrite mais par
contre des fouilles à des sondages
archéologiques qui ont été faits dans
l'église à proprement parler on est est
remonté jusqu'à la période mérovingienne
donc c'était à tester sans problème
eliane luxe donc est à vos côtés voilà
qui a eu encore toi qui a écrit
plusieurs ouvrages 1 / c'est sur cette
ville deux ouvrages le dernier
guyancourt mon histoire a même été
récompensé il n'ya pas longtemps la
dordogne formé association lambeaux de
la ville qu'est ce qui vous passionne
dans cette histoire de guyancourt
beaucoup quand vous travaillez cette
histoire c'est plusieurs années
c'est une ville qui est passionnant
parce qu'en fait elle est riche en
histoire aussi bien dans le passé
puisque on a pu retrouver des documents
aux archives départementales des
yvelines et aux archives nationales qui
atteste la présence d'un certain nombre
de seniors qui sont
renommés et qui ont joué un rôle
important dans l'histoire de france sur
notre territoire et puis il ya toute
cette richesse au niveau de la vie
rurale et toute l'agriculture avec les
grandes fermes qu'il y a eu sur le
plateau sur le plateau de saclay et
naturellement sur lui en cours et puis
il ya également toute cette richesse au
niveau de l'art urbain aussi bien au
niveau de la construction des
habitations que sur les sculptures que
nous pouvons trouver un petit peu
partout dans nos quartiers donc
sur toi vont pouvoir découvrir cette
histoire parce que vous avez participé
donc avec la commune l'anc est au coeur
du village rallye patrimoine il avait
organisé notamment comment ça va se
passer pour du blé qui a brisé j'avais
participé je veux dire tout simplement
que christine henriette la directrice de
la culture de guyancourt et isabelle de
l'aveu gourmelen
m'ont demandé de me joindre à elle pour
comment
organiser will à bord et si vous voulez
le parcours
intitulé enquête au coeur du village
cette scène est l'idée est que les
équipes en dos le temps de ce parcours
le nom d'un détective
et tout ce parcours il y a 18 18 étapes
correspondant à 18 questions avec avec
des aigles nîmes pour justement les
amener à
trouver
les comment
les
les réponses les réponses sont en train
de chasser me cache cache et voilà que
les personnes l'aiguillon cortois même
qui habite au village ne soupçonne pas
donc on les invite à regarder à observer
et c'est des questions faciles que ça
parce que si vous visitez patrimoine ou
encore une
fameuse fresque cette fameuse fresque on
pourra voir rosien d'autres jouent bien
d'autres choses et d le patrimoine c'est
sans arrêt des recherches et des
découvertes donc il ya plein de
nouvelles choses questions essentielles
on peut s'y inscrire en contre
l'isolément clos toreau s'allume même si
on n'est pas guillon pourtant mais qu'on
en saura plus sur la ville absolument au
contraire vous êtes bienvenus
évidemment rapprochez-vous un des
services de la ville de guyancourt il ya
un autre rendez-vous promenons-nous au
village balade historique là aussi c'est
gratuit inscription indispensable on
peut contacter les services de la ville
tout à fait merci à tous les deux d'être
passé j'aurais juste quand même toute
dernière question est-ce qu'ils sont
nombreux dans la ville de lui en cours
être autant passionné par l'histoire de
leur commune culligan gex et bien oui
oui tout à fait on a des revendications
mais celle ci quand même les ailes et
d'une générosité en plus exemplaire
puisque son livre se vend pour une
association c'est bien de le rappeler on
va aller là aussi on voit faire les
services de la municipalité pour en
savoir encore plus merci donc à toutes
les deux